Lumos maxima
serious thing time
you're a wizard you're looking at the
memories
you're an interesting man mr. Scamander
it's getting closer
this is a beast
whatever it is it must be stopped in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
you're learning about a part of magical
history that's talked about in the
Potter books but you never see I'm
getting a chance to tell that now
in the 1920s magic develop very
differently in America many wizards have
suppressed their magic to avoid being
persecuted by muggles they are death
while living in hiding hear my words and
heed my warning
witches live amana they're looking to
its those wizards and witches
if they succeed we will be forced to
stay in the shadows forever and we've
both lived in the shadows for too long
the strange things going on all over the
city people behind this are not like you
and me
just look at the evidence
because of this tension The Wizarding
World the seen a state of high alert at
that time the new comes to New York and
one of his creatures gets out he's
immediately arrested beasts are threat
to giving away that wizard sexists
impound that case grace please you don't
understand nothing in those dangers will
be the judges of that Graves is the head
or puke investigates anything
detrimental to was a kind so setting a
pack of dangerous creatures loose here
was just another accident that's that
what you're telling me I wonder what
makes Albus Dumbledore so fond of Europe
we don't really know who's good and
who's bad until all the chips have
fallen
you know which of your creatures was
responsible mr. skin member look at the
rocks no creature did this
this could mean exposure took me more we
got a plan right guys they need our help
this is new material
there are ways in which we connect to
the Potter books that I think people
will find surprising
this is related to Grendel world attacks
in Europe we're talking about the first
time a wizard rose and threatened the
world order I assumed the vision of
immense power
this was always where I was interested
in going
this is what I wanted to do
you
you